you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the bread and butter
method of genomics how to improve your
qPCR presenting live from Hamburg is dr.
Tim Sean marks global marketing manager
automation and PCR Eppendorf I'm
Christie jewel of lab rats and I will be
our moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by labyrinth and sponsored by
Eppendorf for more information on our
sponsor please visit at the NORTHCOM now
before we begin I would like to
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box located on the left
and click the send button we will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation additionally
we will be conducting a few interactive
polls throughout the webinar today and
we appreciate your participation now if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the
support tab at the top right of the
presentation window or just let us know
you're experiencing a problem by using
the ask a question box this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits to obtain
your credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process I would
now like to introduce today's presenter
dr. Tim Shaw marks dr. Shaw marts is a
global marketing manager automation and
PCR at Eppendorf headquartered in
Hamburg Germany for a complete biography
of our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
now let's get started Tim the stage is
yours
Christie thank you so much for this nice
introduction I want to welcome everyone
and thank you for tuning in a warm good
afternoon from Hamburg Germany and
before I begin I want to apologize for
any upcoming background noise but there
has just been a construction site
starting in front of my office window
and there seems to be some really
important jackhammer work being going on
but that's the beauty of the live
webinar so I want to talk about the
bread and butter method of genomics
namely PCR and qPCR it's a method that
is very widespread and a lot of laps
around the world and I want to share
some insights from the Eppendorf
perspective on this very important
method this webinar should be
interactive at least as interactive as
it can be and therefore in order to get
to know you a little bit better I would
like to start with a poll I want to know
what is the main purpose of PCR in your
lab you can click as many answers as you
want so are you using PCR mainly for
cloning for example for CRISPR cos or
protein engineering are you doing
genotyping forensics are you using TDI
to prepare it to prepare your next
generation sequencing libraries are you
using PCR for quantitative analysis
let's say qpcr or in a qualitative
matter a standard endpoint PCR or do you
have any other PCR applications so I see
that the first answers are coming in
thank you very much for sharing this I
will read it again what is the main
purpose of PCR in your lab are you using
PCR for cloning genotyping forensics to
prepare your next generation sequencing
libraries for quantitative analysis
qualitative analysis or for something
different
just a couple more seconds
[Music]
okay
thank you very much it's really
interesting a lot of you guys are using
qpcr I can see and then it's followed by
genotyping and next-generation
sequencing as well as qualitative
analysis so thank you very much for
sharing this information
this helps us here at Eppendorf to
further improve our our products and
services okay so let me come back to PCR
and I think that you have seen it slide
like this a lot of time so the basic
principles of PCR so you start with the
denaturation of a double-stranded DNA so
you get two single strands then you come
to the annealing phase where the primers
anneal and you get to the extension
phase where you multiply your your PCR
or your DNA and in the end you got two
copies and by that you are multiplying
your input materials so I think you have
seen that a hundred times as well as the
basic principle of qPCR where you are
introducing some sort of reporter it can
be a specific reporter like a beacon or
a probe or something more unspecific
like intercalating die in principle it
follows the same process as a regular
PCR just at at the end and you are
measuring a fluorescence or during the
process you're measuring a fluorescence
and this will reflect the the amount of
your input material making it possible
to do a quantitative analysis so what is
needed for a PCR of course of course you
need some import material
sounds from DNA you need reagents you
need some material some cubes or place
where you are performing your PCR and
you need some sort of thermal cyclers
which is needed for a PCR so those
components are connected by a process
because you have to get all of those
things together in order to get your PCR
up and running and what I think is
usually very important that I'm doing a
PCR is not something which is isolated
in the lab so there is usually some
upstream processes and some downstream
processes and when I was approaching the
webinar I was really thinking what I
want to present you and I was looking
into the material which is available out
there and I found a lot of webinars
dealing with the input material with the
reagents how to adjust this in order to
get perfect PCR results so you can find
a lot of lists which looks like this so
how to optimize your DNA template how to
optimize your primer how you can play
around with the other additives in order
to get your to get your PCR up and
running and how in order to solve your
problem so I put on my thinking cap and
I thought that okay I think it doesn't
make sense to make another webinar
presenting you the exact same stuff so
what I want to do during that webinar I
want to focus on those things which are
often overlooked so I want to look
closer and at the consumables which I
use during the PCR process and how those
can help to improve your PCR of course I
want to look at the instrumentation and
I want to put my focus on the process
itself so what is the best strategy to
put together the PCR aside from choosing
a polymerase or a certain buffer so
let's start with the liquid handling 101
for PCR
and if you take something from this
webinar if you just remember one thing
it should be this thing so if you do a
PCR always always prepare a master mix
and master mix is key for a successful
TCR what you can see depicted here on
this slide is if you have several
samples and you start with one master
mix you will have the exact same amount
of the different components and in all
of your reaction if you lit up your
master mix into two tube you will always
have variability and this variability
will be reflected in your different
samples so do a master mix and do a
master mix for every set of primers that
you have so even if you have 10 sets of
primaries you should do 10 master mixes
don't try to put your reagents together
one by one so it's important to teach
our master mixes and I would always
account for 10 to 20% overage when you
are preparing your master mix I would
use one Wessel for one mix so don't
split your mix up so don't prepare it in
two separate vessels the results will
vary I would always start by pipetting
with the component with the highest
volume and you should add your enzymes
last so that they can stay cool as long
as possible there are two other tips and
which I followed while I was working in
the lab so I would always aliquot on the
stock solution
just in case when you put together your
mix set if you do a piping mistake so
let's say if you go with your tip which
contains the primer into the tube of
your polymerase that you are not
contaminating your total amount of the
polymerase but just that one aliquot
that you are using for the
particular style and I would also in the
same respect
aliquot primer dilution so that even is
one as part of the primal dilutions is
contaminated for whatever reason you can
go back to your stock either create a
new dilutions or you take out a new
aliquot so the quick experts um how can
consumables help you with those other
parts so there is a technology called
protein low by four cubes and as you can
see here in that slide if you add up
what your enzymes in this kind of cubes
you won't lose any protein into the
plastic material so your enzymes stays
intact during long-term storage so once
you put together your master mix and you
mix it through you might experience that
sometimes it can be tricky to handle
masa mixers they can be for me sometimes
they are very viscous and there are a
few tips and tricks what you can do in
order to handle those things so one
option is slow and steady reverse type
of thing I will come to that in a minute
if you have like really tricky mixes you
can use positive statement systems and
there is the option of using automation
to this I will come a little later so
what do I mean with slow and steady
reverse pipetting so regular pipetting
what you know in the lab it's what we
described here as forward type of thing
so if you have a manual pipette you
press down to the first stop
then you immerse your tip into the
liquid and then you slowly release the
button and when you want to release your
liquid you press it all the way through
to to the second stop and by that you're
pushing out all of the liquid so but if
you have a mix which is for me and
viscous sometimes using
in Reverse pipetting it's the better
strategy here so what you do there is
you press the whole way down to the
second stop and then you emerge your tip
into the liquid then you slowly release
the button until you come up to the
correct position and then you press the
button down to the first stop and this
will leave a little bit of liquid in the
tip but it helps you to handle viscous
and foamy liquids so this is a good
strategy for constant and precise
pipetting of more difficult liquids
meaning liquids which are not accurate
so
another small expert on a consumable so
how the right tip can help you so what
you can see here on the left is a
regular tip and on the right hand side
is so called low retention tip and I
think that you've all experienced that
in the lab so if you're handling a very
viscous liquid sometimes they tend to
stick to the tip and eww it's really
hard to get them off and this leads to a
loss of final volume in the tube so this
is what what's happening to me when I
was working in the lab I was preparing
my master mix and then I was putting my
experiment to work together and I was I
counted for some overage and in the end
I figured out oh no I'm missing like
three samples and the reason is I was
losing material to the tip and by using
low retention tips you can overcome that
and those of you more experienced with
PCR you could already see something with
the tips I would always highly encourage
you to use positive in all scenarios
where you're working with PCR because
even the slightest traces of DNA or
nucleic acid due to the multiplying
nature of the PCR process they will be
multiplied in your son
and you will see cross-contamination
so what helps you there is a good tip
quality here at Eppendorf we use
different purity grade we have one
purity grade called PCR clean which are
made for doing CCR so you can be sure
that you don't introduce anything with
your tip and the serger avoid
cross-contamination and by aerosols so
again let me tell you a quick story from
my time in the lab I was working in a
very ology lab and at some point people
from another department were coming over
to our lab asking us that they can do
their TC arts and our lab and the reason
was that they were working with ethnic
viruses and they were not using
relatives so all of the types in their
labs were contaminated with techno viral
DNA so all of the experiments they were
doing all of the negative controls they
were positive at the end for ethno viral
DNA so then they've cleaned up all of
their pipettes
that's also a good measure from time to
time
Desson checks and senior pipette and
then they change to positives and by
that day became rid of this problem so
don't underestimate traces of DNA in
your packet so I also mentioned positive
displacement so this comes into play
when you have a liquid which is really
trickle too tricky to handle if you take
a regular air crushin pipette as you can
see on the left hand side you have a
piston and in between the piston and the
liquid there is a air cushion and
depending on the properties of this
liquid this air cushion sometimes can
make the handling difficult so let's say
if you had a very warm liquid or cold
liquid or also something which is
volatile or very viscous
in contrast a positive displacement
system often also called stepper
as an example would be the multi-site on
the right hand side the piston is in
direct contact with the liquid and by
this you can handle difficult liquid
avoiding effects which are due to the
air cushion okay there are some
additional requirements for qPCR which I
think you are aware of so in order to do
qpcr you need a lot of biological and
technical replicates to get reliable
results
so this resides in a high sample number
and many PI packing steps sometimes
you're also required to work with low
volume in order to account for low
volume I would recommend to either do
contact type of thing so anything below
let's say 1 microliter I would recommend
to type it with liquid contact so put
let's say your master mix first and then
at your sample which is of low volume
directly into that existing liquid in
your plate or tube another option is to
work with dilution that would be my
suggestion and so that um dilute your
sample where you need a very low volume
in order to get it to a dispensing
volume which is handled o/q the nature
of qPCR makes it very sensitive for
piloting mistakes so you need to work
with high precision and since usually
worst comes words and so for me it was
often the case that qpcr was linked to
normalization so i had to do
normalization first and after that i had
to do with qpcr and that increase the
number of type of thing steps
dramatically so if you have a scenario
like this and i would really recommend
to think about automation i will talk
about automation strategies in a minute
but first i want to present you
a trick I call it tips tricks it's not
patented or so it's just something that
I did in the lab and I wanted to share
it with you so maybe it makes your life
and your qPCR pipetting easier as well
so I call it the to dot or two drops
technique so what you can see here it's
a very simple depiction of a well of a
plate so what happened to me a lot of
times is when I was typing the qPCR then
and somebody came into the lab was
talking to me or so I looked up and at
that very moment I forgot a twitch well
I was did I get my sample already or not
then I sometimes edit the sample twice
because I forgot which where I was so
I'm used and then I use the strategy
with the two dots so what I did first is
I put my master mix at the lower part of
the vessel and directly at the wall at
the wall and due to the surface tension
it was sticking there in the second step
I was putting my sample a little bit
higher on the wall of the well and this
enables you to see if you look at the
place in which was you have piped your
master mix and also your sample so it's
much easier to keep track of the process
and to combine those two things you are
simply giving it a quick spin in the
centrifuge and then these two drops move
downwards and they combine in the bottom
of the plate another release is the use
of electronic pipette and mighty this
panic mode so if you work with a regular
type of thing it means you are taking up
one volume and you're releasing the
exact same volume my little sense in
comparison and you take up a multiple of
this volume and can then this 10 several
times so this and speeds up the process
this is a big relief for you
hands especially if you're already in
the risk of getting RSI so I would
personally recommend using electronic
pipette for qPCR setup or as mentioned
automation so but before we come to
automation and I want to talk a little
bit about the vessels so what I show you
here are some very common vessels and
that I used for PCR and qPCR so it
ranges from single tubes over eight
strips to 96-well plates and then to
384-well plate so and what I want to
know from you is and what kind what kind
of vessels are you using for your PCR is
single cube cube strips 96-well plates
384 well plates or something in a
completely different format again you
can choose different answers and I can
see that slowly the first answers are
coming in so let me read the question
again what vessels meaning tubes or
plates are you using for your PCR is it
single cubes is it cube strip is this 96
well plate is it 384 well plate or is it
something completely different
you
so thank you very much for your answers
coming in
is to import those a 96-well plates are
in the lead followed by tube strips and
they're the other things are in the
third respectively spot place very
interesting thank you very much this
really helps us to adjust our portfolio
so I will slowly move on to the next
slide so no matter what you are using
for your PCR there are some things that
I would look out for so the most
important thing is that you choose a
consumable which has optimal heat
transfer because the the heat and
temperature cycling is the most
important process step of any PCR and
just that the actual device is giving
you a temperature doesn't mean that
let's say if a block had 90 degrees that
those 90 degrees reach your samples and
in order especially if you are running
PCR was passed PCR let's say you want to
have optimal heat transfer but
especially if we talk about place and
talk about downstream methods and those
of you who look we're working with NGS
library presentation will know that you
are also looking for sturdy shape so
that means that after the place in this
case has come to some heat and you don't
want it to bend and work because maybe
you want to do a beach cleanup
afterwards
unfortunately optimally transfer and 30
chase and
different types of plastics have these
peasants properties so if you have
something which has a very good heat
transfer it's usually not very Derby and
if you have something which is pretty
sturdy it doesn't have a very good heat
transfer and therefore in terms of clays
Eppendorf invented these twin take place
and they are using two types of plastics
polypropylene if I'm not mistaken for
the cubes because they have optimal heat
transfer and the casing is made of
polycarbonate which is very sturdy
another advantage of very sturdy shape
is that this is automation automation
friends and that means if something is
grabbed by a robotic arm you don't want
this arm to crush the plate so if you
have a very dirty place and those things
are better suited for automation and of
course you want your place to have a
certain purity grade so that your
example does not get contaminated okay
so again a little expert on there is a
special technology called DNA low bind
and this is especially important if you
are thinking about long term storage of
your PCR tumbles what you can see in
this slide is a storage in a standard
plate of illegal um and you can see that
you lose some illegal because it
interacts with the plastic and once you
take it out of the place you cannot
recover a hundred percent of your PCR
product if you use Loman place instead
you can have a long-term storage and
still have a hundred percent recovery if
this is interesting for you we have some
more data on that but if you think about
long-term storage I would really
recommend the
a long low buying materials finally we
come to automation so that's my favorite
one of my favorite topics I was working
with the advent of automation team for a
long time and what I have seen a lot of
times in the past that if I talk about
automation and PCR people think about
this so if you are running several 384
well plates of PCR a day a month
whatever it's pretty clear that people
are looking for automation but I want to
show you that it's also useful to think
about automating your PCR if you're
working in a completely different
throughput range namely a strip and
96-well plate because the problem is
when people think about automation they
mainly think about something this size
like this guy it's massive it's
complicated it's really hard to get it
into your lab but what I want to show
you is that nowadays automation comes in
in many titles so there are other
automation solutions which are just as
versatile but way smaller and really
easy to handle so what I wanna show you
here are three different automation
solutions from Eppendorf on the if you
motion series smallest one fifty seventy
then fifty seventy three and the easy
motion and fifty seventy five and they
have different sizes and these different
sizes they account for the complexity of
the application but also for the
throughput and so if you look at a PCR
which is not like a super complex
application and a qPCR might be of
medium complexity you can see that
depending on your throughput there is a
sweet spot for all kinds of automation
right you can either go for a smaller
device or for the
I'll just divide or you go for the
device in the middle and why is this is
important because the lab reality
usually looks like this so big at least
it's what I know from my lab and space
precious sometimes it's very crowded so
you need to have some space put your
device on usually you don't have an
extra room to spare for automation and
this is why the these devices are not
maximum size so the smallest one is just
about four eight four letters for Europe
or us letter size
the other ones are respectively six or
ten US letters or a4 paper sizes and I
apologize because I know that the
popular scientific measurement of size
is football spheres and of liquid this
Olympic swimming pools but I hope you
stick with me that I go for a fourth and
us better size in this respect so what
can automate and do for you if you do
PCR qPCR so first of all it takes over
the whole PCR or qPCR setup it's never
forget the wells and the documents each
and every step automatically and it can
account for all of the tips and tricks I
have mentioned so far I will lead you
through that and most and foremost it
does not have any risks so especially if
you do qpcr if you do a lot of type of
things and changing to automation is a
big relief for your wrist because the
piloting is done by the robot so the
essence of automation solutions they are
capable of using different types of
vectors and this is really important
because most likely if you if you
consider automation you would stick with
the system with the plastics and with
the reagents that you already have
you can see here on the left-hand side
and that there are special reservoirs
which account for different sized cubes
size melody two tubes one point five
milliliter tubes 8 strips so you can
handle several a strips at the same time
but of course automation also works in a
place homeless may it be 96 well plate
or 384 eject automation can handle
difficult liquid so this is a screenshot
which I took from our automation
software as called et blue and what you
can see here is that you can adjust all
of the piping or dispensing settings in
a very detailed session but there is
also the option to simply select a
preset set sorry I'm off different
liquid so for example PCR premix and
something like ethanol glycerol and the
system even accounts for contact
dispensing if we talk about really low
volumes of course automation systems
they can use both a pipe mode and mighty
dispense mode so basically and they are
capable in doing everything that the
electronic pipette can do and more and
to sum it up so automation is very
versatile this is what I've mentioned
before so besides PCR you can also do
something like a normalization this is
where automation shines actually so if
you do anything which is really
pipetting heavy you have a versatile
system first you do your normalization
then you move into your qpcr on the very
same system they are flexible for four
different throughput and they are
accurate and precise error free you get
a tracking of your sample
during the whole process and they can
increase your productivity because it
frees your time to do something
different while the robot is doing the
work and they prevent contamination
because they have the the ethanol
automation solution they have a full
housing and they can also be equipped
with HEPA filter and UV light and they
protect you as well makes maybe not so
important for PCR qPCR but let's say if
you are handling blood samples that that
might be of important and of course I
think the the biggest thing is that they
improve the standardization and
reproducibility because no matter who is
operating the automat the results will
be the same a robot doesn't have a bad
day a robot is not in the best mood
sometimes so that's that's a big class
and it's and if you would have if you
are and to know that sometimes if you
are doing repetitive pipetting work this
can be very tiring and you can use this
time to do much more important tasks and
let's face it the major story for piping
errors in the lab is unfortunately the
type of user all right what is very
important for automation in general is
that if you have such a thing exist
where a lot of people out rate of this
that you get you get something where you
need to learn coding which is really
really complicated I can assure you that
the essent of systems are very easy to
program it's the simple drag-and-drop
based method I don't want to go through
all of the details because we have a
webinar dedicated just to that one it's
called into which is an easy programming
of liquid handling tasks with the et
motion where you can learn how to set up
a PCR
really quickly using EPE to motion robot
alright so after talking a lot of
obviously its emotion and
Automation in general I just want to
know how many city art are you actually
running from one in your lap an average
is it less than ten and you do this in
cubes or strip is it less than ten but
in place is it between 10 or 30 or is it
more than 30 a month and of course it
does not only account for PCR but also
social PCR I didn't put that in the fall
year so I can see that the first answers
are coming in so some are really heavy
PCR users while others are just doing
PCR occasionally it's very interesting
so how many PCR are you running per
month on average is it less than 10
tubes or stripes is it less than 10 and
play between 10 and 30 or more than 30
okay think two more seconds
you guys are doing a lot of PCR as I see
this the answers are coming in because
most of you who are actually doing
between 10 and 30 or more than 30 that's
that's really interesting alright so
thanks a lot for your answers and now we
finally come to the pink elephant in the
room because you might ask yourself what
is this guy talking about all the time
about the process about robots about
tubes and everything so what what about
the cycler so there is no PCR without a
cycler and I will I will talk about a
regular PC outside this year I will not
touch qPCR cyclists and but there are of
course some some general texts which you
can take from your regular PCR cyclists
and also transfer into qPCR cyclers so
what is important for a cycler and from
my perspective it's several things and
if first of all the flexibility for
tubes and clay I think it's a big class
if you have the option to work with
different formats in the same device so
that you can put single tubes a stripes
that you can put 96-well plates and that
for the place it doesn't make any
difference as they are skirted semi
skirted or non skirted but I what I was
to think is very important which is
overlooked a lot of times is the block
homogeneity I will come to that in a
minute and and and I think that controls
heating and cooling and the big
advantage a lot of times people talk
about rain breaks which sort of defines
the speed of the cycler
I think yes REM braids are important it
highly depends on your application but I
personally don't think that ran braids
are the one and only thing to go for I
think that the other things that as I
mentioned here are more important if you
decide for a cycler so what do I mean
with block homogeneity so you might know
that the heating and cooling of a cycler
is done by Peltier elements so these are
the things which are doing the heating
and cooling and this is the most
technical slide that I have a mobile
presentation and there is two different
ways to fix them so you can have the
eating area with a center fixing as as
depicted on the left hand side or you
can have the heating area with a site
fixing as depicted on the right hand
side I can tell you that the Eppendorf
master cycler except it is using center
fixing so but what does it mean if we
have a center fixed or or 5/6 element so
on top you see the center fixed elements
that means that due to the center fixing
there is only if I jump back to that
slide and there's only like a very teeny
tiny spot in the very center of each of
those elements where you don't have a
perfect temperature homogeneous 'ti that
means and consequence that all of your
samples running on that cycler no matter
if they are in the center of the well or
at the edge you will always get the same
results because you will always get the
exact temperature that you set and if we
look at another cycler which is used
in sight fixing which you can see these
are the dance shown at the bottom you
can see that due to the seismic thing
you have the so called edge effect so
due to the due to the fixing you don't
get the same heat performance and Edward
words which are at the edge of the plate
and the consequences that you are losing
quite some capacity on your plate or
even worse if you don't know it you are
basically sacrificing samples or even
sacrificing your whole experiment
because some of your most important
samples maybe controls might not work
because they are in a non optimal
position the second thing is control
heating and cooling so if we talk about
the ramping and if you can if you reach
a certain level we talked about a
temperature over and understood that
means that as a comparison on the left
hand side you can see a pin drop cycle
on the right hand side you can see
another cycler so if we say we want to
heat the cycle to a temperature of 95
degrees the essence of cycler only has a
very small overshoot of about 99 degrees
whereas the other cycler has a heavy
overshoot of 107 degrees so this will
increase drastically decrease your
enzyme half-life and by that with using
your yield at the same time during the
cooling you can have a undershoot so if
you say if you want to go to a
temperature of 35 degrees on the ascent
of cycler only undershoots
to thirty thirty two point five degrees
whereas the other cycler understood
quite heavily to 29 degrees and this
will give rise to non specific bang so
that is like a very small thing which is
often overlooked but that can really
make a difference for more complicated
PCRs so and I've been talking for quite
a while now so
I will come to a summary so I hope you
remember and the slide that I've shown
you in the very beginning and with the
whole process so I was some of what I
have talked about so far so if we take a
first look at the process so the most
important thing the most important thing
prepare master mixes prepare master mix
this is really key for successful MTCR
if you use manual pipettes
I would recommend to get yourself
familiar with the with the technique of
reword pipetting or switch to electronic
pipette and if they make life much
easier
physicists can save samples and nurse
and of course I would always recommend
to consider automation take a look at
automation think about it once you have
it you will never give it away I promise
for the vessels use the correct vessel
and size and and shape for your fault
for your experiment as I said no matter
if it is its place or cubes and think
about the thing about the heat transfer
and think about the sturdiness choose
the right purity for important
experiments so don't sacrifice your
sample by using low quality consumables
seals I haven't talked about that very
much but seals can avoid night shifts
honestly nothing is more frustrating if
you come back to the lab in the morning
and you see that your still was not
price and everything evacuated during
the run so check your seals go with high
quality seals oils or lips if you are
not sure about the seal and do a test
run just using water and running your
PCR cycle with that
here and if you consider automation go
for weapons with which are suited for
automation so as I've shown you the
Eppendorf automation solutions they are
very flexible but especially if you go
for play look for a sturdy plate which
can be grabbed by a robot arm so for the
cycler I would always go for something
which is flexible so that you can use
different vessels so may be cubes or
plays on the same cycler a good block
homogeneity lets you use a whole set if
you're using plate and not only half of
it or so and go for control heating and
cooling for perfect results and with
that I will come to my last two slides I
want to end with a citation of Kary
Mullis the inventor of PCR who recently
passed away and he said that sometimes
in the morning when it's a good start I
go out there and I don't feel like it's
a bad word and I know that working in
the lab can sometimes be frustrating if
you don't get an experiment to work it
can be very frustrating but with that I
want to end on a very positive and
optimistic note and be positive things
will work out if you follow those tips
and tricks I'm pretty sure and that you
will get your experiment up and running
and you will get really good results and
with that I want to finish I want to
close the presenting part of this
webinar and I'm handing back to Christie
for the moment
thank you Tim for that excellent
presentation now before we begin our
life to an a portion of the webinar we
love your audience participation in our
final poll we would like your answers
and your answers are very important
election may help us improve our webinar
program so okay let's get started on our
Q&A portion as a reminder if you have a
question you would like to ask him
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and any questions that we
are not able to answer live today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period Tim will be answering them via
email at the email address you provided
during the time of your registration
okay so let's get started let's see
we've got some great questions coming in
let's see Tim our first question
we end this one is caught in a couple
times is there any way to spend any way
to speed up a PCR um oh yeah that's a
that that's actually a good question and
I would say that this is that this is
something which is highly situational so
there are ways to speed up a PCR
[Music]
sometimes you can use five PCR reagents
so there are fast PCR enzymes and fast
PCR yeah other reagents another option
is if you have a suited PCR what we have
at Eppendorf so called fast PCR
consumables
these are only strips and it's a it's a
very thin walled material so I these
work for certain PCRs where you can
switch to this kind of place and here I
have to come back to the ramp right of
course and ramp right can make a
difference so if you have a cycler with
high ramp race where heating and cooling
is very fast you can speed up a PCR
using this cycler um for the Eppendorf
cycler we have different block types we
have aluminium block which is already
very fast but for the high-performance
and also high throughput we have a
silver block cycler as well because
silver has very good heat transfer
capability you can go for a silver block
cycler and that makes it really fast
thank you can now let's go with this
next question what is a technical
replica
yeah a good question and I meant it I
mentioned that in in one of my slides
and this is the term of technical and
biological replicate something that I
used during
qpcr experiment and I think it's sort of
widespread but sometimes people don't
really know what it is
so for me the best explanation is the
biological replicates what I say you
want to correlate the expression of the
certain gene with a certain condition or
with a certain set of donors so a
biological replicate would be to have
several donors or blood samples where
you suspect them to have the same
treatment that would be a biological
replicate where at the technical
replicate is a sample that comes from
one donor or one source and it's been
split up into several portions so let's
say a triplicate or a duplicate the
reason why you're doing is is that with
the biological replicates
you are controlling your hypothesis so
your experimental hypothesis
whereas with your technical replicate
you are controlling your process in this
respect let's say your pipetting for
example or your your precision in
general
thank you for that clarification Tim now
how do I know which setting to choose
for my liquid when I am using a robot
um yeah that is also a pretty pretty
good question so it brings me back to
the slide and maybe I can quickly go to
that slide where I was showing a
different pipetting parameter
I think it's that like yes so first of
all yes you can you can go with the
Dupree setting that I think it's the
easiest way at least for the for the
ethanol system so if you are using PCR
premix go for PCR premix if you're using
glycerol go for I thought so but then
you can also change a lot of the
parameters manually so the expiration
speeds the dispensing speed and stuff
like that and I have to tell you and to
my understanding it's not a very exact
science it is a little bit of trial and
error but there are some rules of thumb
so for example if you have something
which is very viscous I would go for a
very slow expiration speed and a very
slow distending speed and I would also
use a blowout so I would prefer a
pipetting mode over a mighty dispense
mode because the blood can kick out this
last little bit of liquid and from your
tip for example if you work with
something which is very volatile um I
would always go for pre vetting because
with this pre vetting you avoid dripping
with your offshore liquid out of your
out of your tips anyhow if you are not
sure what are the best settings for your
liquid you can always come back to us
contact us here at Eppendorf we have a
test lab we can even test that for you
and so we can support you find the
setting
Thank You Tim now what is the skirted
plate
oh yeah I've mentioned that right I'm
not entirely sure if this is a common
widespread term so I learned it when I
started here at Eppendorf but that might
also be a language thing because a few
if you might have noticed I know I'm not
a native speaker so um we distinguish
between dirty or fully skirted semi
skirted or non skirted play so a fully
skirted play is a place which has this
kind of color around it which reaches to
the bottom so basically if it has some
sort of frame and the frame has the same
size at your best so if you are putting
it on a flat table top it will stand on
both the tubes and the frame this allows
for example for using it in several
devices without the need of an adapter a
semi skirted plate has this sort of
frame cut in half so you if you look
from the side you can see the West but
it still has some sort of residual frame
it's one of the most commonplace for
example used for India's library
preparation it has the advantage that it
can carry more volume um but it can
still be transported by a robot arm and
then we have a unscarred on non skirted
plate and that basically means that it
does not have any sort of frame so you
if you look from the side you can see
the whole the whole well for a semi and
then non-square displayed if you work
with that on a robot you usually need an
adapter to securely place it on the deck
so and this is
what I mentioned if I talked about PCR
cyclers it depends so there are some
devices out there where you can only put
one type of play so only non sordid
plays let's say right so and I would
always prefer something which is
independent of the shape of your with
the shape of your plate
now can while we're on the topic of
plates what is a better plate the
transparent will right
good question it's not this is it's not
an easy answer so if you go for a
regular PCR it doesn't matter so it can
be transparent it it can be white so
because there is no actual detection
step and worse than that if we talk
about qPCR there is a tendency to use a
white plate because they do have better
reflection purposes so in this respect I
personally would prefer a white plate
and if you go for a transparent plate I
would do a test run
besides the plate and also it's not only
the plate which is important it's also
the seal so for the seal you you usually
need them a very transparent high
quality clear seal in order to route you
PCR to get your your best result
Thank You Tim now we're almost out of
time so we're going to wrap with this
final question how does automated
normalization work
okay well that's actually something
which I explained and the other sort of
advertised webinar but in in principle
the the automated normalization works
similar to what you would do manually so
you would you have let's say certain
number of samples and you have a diluent
and then you will put the diluent and
the samples together in a way that you
end up with a place where you have all
of your samples having the exact same
concentration if you've ever done it you
know that this can be like super tedious
and it's super error-prone because you
have to change the volume all the time
you have to go forth and back so for
automation so at least for the ethanol
solution there are there are two ways um
the the first way which I would not
recommend this program it by hand so you
can start with your exit excel sheet
let's say or your hand written sheet or
whatever you have and then you can
program each and every step by hand
saying okay sample one I want to have 20
microliters of DNA and then at
Sergi microliter I went let's say the
better way is to use a very easy CBS
import function so this works in a way
that we would provide you with a special
format excel sheet where you can put it
in let's say your concentrations maybe
also coming straight from a measurement
and then you can decide what how you
want to normalize it you want to have
normalized volumes you want to have
normalized concentrations and then you
can save this file as a CSV file and
then you just have to import the CSV
file into the automation software and
the system will automatically translate
that CSV file into pipetting commands by
that making it actually very convenient
to deal with normalization and
especially with changing normalization
every day but it is pretty well
explained in the webinar that I have
mentioned on one of my previous slide
thank you Tim now before we go I want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
as a reminder those questions we did not
have time to answer today and those
submitted during our on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Shah Marzia the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration I would like to
once again thank dr. Tim Shaw marks for
his time today and his excellent
presentation we'd also like to thank lab
Rouge and our sponsor Eppendorf for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay I encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be redirected to
the registration page of our next
webinar from cell seating to analysis
getting the best out of your cell based
assays presented by Eppendorf very own
dr. Jessica Wagner and dr. Eric Duncan
of poor Megha
this webinar will broadcast live on
September 10th at 6 a.m. Pacific time
9:00 a.m. Eastern Time and 3 p.m. c EST
we hope to see you there so we say
goodbye from Hamburg and California have
a great day